assalamualaikum
welcome back to the realist podcast in
the dona the three muslims we're joined
here with a very special guest today
brother abu ibrahim was named
so
seems like a lot of the viewers on the
on the stream are familiar with your
work uh this brother's been watching
since 2013.
uh let's see
so let's get everyone really good topics
looking forward to this hamdulillah
always wanted to learn more about jin
yep that's why we're here today
all right let's see so before we go
right in i wanted to mention um to the
brothers if you could give us a little
bit of an intro on what you do who you
are and i don't know how anyone uh made
it this far without knowing who you are
but just for those people that don't
know who you are why don't you introduce
yourself
alhamdulillah
allah
we begin
by praising allah sending peace and
salutations upon the messenger
firstly i want to thank you brothers for
giving me this opportunity and this
invitation
um as i was mentioning earlier i i
wasn't really aware that these kind of
podcasts existed alhamdulillah and it's
a major nerama from allah that we have
brothers from
different parts of the world and we we
can connect and come together upon
as allah says you know come together and
cooperate upon righteousness and piety
so alhamdulillah so thank you for this
opportunity first and foremost
to answer your question really i'm i'm a
nobody i'll be honest with you um just a
normal brother who um got involved with
roxia
um and and this field of gin and magic
and the evil eye and these kind of
things and didn't get involved willingly
sort of fell into it um there were um
there were situations where um you know
members of the family extended family
etc needed this kind of thing and um as
the as the practicing one or somebody
who looked practicing all understand you
know the family turned to me and said
hey we need we need you to help us in
this so um i kind of got involved
inadvertently but what i found was that
there was a lot of ignorance a lot of
misinformation
and a lot of just cloudiness and people
were being um taken advantage of and
that's one thing that me personally i i
really don't like is when um people take
advantage of the vulnerable and they um
and they abuse their powers of position
and trust and that people put in them so
um as a result of that i kind of got
involved in rukkia and um started making
rookie and and going down into this
field and really my aim was uh like what
we're doing here today is to help um
clarify
um the truth from the from the falsehood
um about this topic but also my my
ultimate objective is to attach our
hearts to allah
and to follow the sunnah so that we all
understand we have in
allah confirm
that you have in the messenger of allah
the best of examples that we have
everything that we need and just to
demystify it um and make it easy for our
brothers and sisters who are suffering
subhanallah mubarak so
um i just want to make this clear two
things number one guys if you made it
this far smash that like button for
those of you that are just entering the
chat that's what helps us boost the
algorithm and number two
unlike a lot of episodes where you know
the viewers are gonna get a lot more
than us this one i definitely know that
i'm gonna get a lot more than a lot of
the viewers because i'm extremely
interested and extremely engaged in this
conversation you know so uh before we go
in we're gonna give a quick little
rundown of what we're gonna talk about
today in sha allah uh so we're gonna
start with a brief intro on jin so you
can tell us like for a lot of people
like the layman they don't know what jin
are some people there's a lot of people
that they think these are like metaphors
you know these are not literal things
right next we're going to talk about
what magic is and how it links to the
magician
we can then talk about evil eye gin
possession
we can talk about reasons for gin
possession so if it's out of love or
revenge et cetera et cetera you can go
into that um and then we can end it with
how to cure oneself from affliction and
then because prevention is better than
cure how we can prevent ourselves from
affliction in the first place inshallah
so do you have any questions for us or
anything like that before we go in
uh no um i also just a suggestion
inshallah um if uh if if you brothers um
take questions and things like this from
the from the viewers i think that would
also be very very useful because um
there are even times where to be honest
when i have a talk or or a seminar on
this kind of thing i just give 10
minutes and then i just open the floor
and i say you know whatever questions
you have regarding this topic because
that's one of the best ways to to learn
is through the the questions that the
brothers and sisters have um and often
they
they will have questions that sometimes
maybe i wouldn't have covered or what i
would have overlooked so that's a very
good way of doing it but i'm gonna you
know inshallah you're the lead and i'll
and i'll take your your lead 100 like
the way we do it is we we do like q a at
the end but sometimes i'll put questions
that are relevant like during the stream
so we're never going to shy away from
questions inshallah so if you're okay
with that i'll just pin up some
questions every now and then when
they're relevant um regardless of that
at the end of the podcast we're gonna
definitely pin up some some questions
for like a q a session um so timeline
guys if you made it this far it's
probably gonna be like an hour hour and
a half max uh brother angel does have to
leave a little early unfortunately but
i'll be here with brother abu ibrahim
who's name
just in case so without further ado
we'll go right into it um a quick uh
address that we're asking what rami is
surami's allergies guys so make to
affirm that he can recover and bounce
back uh inshallah very quickly um but
without further ado we'll go right in
so bismillah the first question that we
have is can you give a give a brief
introduction on jinn so what they are
why should we be concerned about them do
they affect us do they not affect us etc
good questions so allah says
that i did not create the jinn and
mankind except to worship me alone so we
we learn from this that there are two
creations here okay one is the jinn
which allah mentions and one is mankind
meaning the people humankind so we are
both created to worship allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
and the story of the jinn as allah says
we created them a four times so jin the
creation of the jinn actually predates
the creation of mankind okay and allah
says we created them
from a smokeless flame of the fire okay
so
this is their creation just like we are
created from uh dust or the the the clay
as it may be allah has created the jinn
from the fire and the angels are created
from light okay so we have three types
of creation with different origins but
the jin the creation of the jinn
predates the creation of mankind the
question that we have now is why is it
important that we learn about their
world well actually
to learn about that we need to go to the
creation of adam alaihis salat
because when allah created adam
we allah says we ordered the angels to
prostrate for
illah iblis so they all prostrated to
adam
except for
iblis this one creature who was with the
angels but allah says
he was from amongst the jinn so he was a
pious worshiper of allah and he was
ordered along with the angels to
prostrate the angels prostrated but this
one creature didn't and allah says why
didn't you prostrate to the one who i
created with my own two hands when i
ordered you iblee said
created him from the clay
so from this point onwards we have an
animosity with iblis and the uh the
followers of iblis because iblee said oh
allah because you have sent me astray
this creation of yours i'm gonna sit and
i'm gonna wait for him and his children
on your straight path i'm gonna come to
them from in front of them from behind
them from their left and from their
right and you're gonna find that most of
them they are not grateful meaning
they're gonna follow me okay so iblis is
from the jinn but at the same time we
need to understand that the jin are not
all bad so this is the clarifying the
first misconce misconception some people
think that the the jinn are like ghouls
and and ghosts and monsters and that
kind of thing they have their world
which
it's it's um it's a parallel world and
it's with us but allah says
that he sees you meaning iblis him and
his tribe him and his offspring from
where you can't see them the gin they
live in this world of ours we can't see
them but they can see us they have their
animals they have their food they have
their drink they you know get married
they have children they they are obliged
to follow uh and worship allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala so the jinn are another
creation but sometimes as we're gonna
learn today the the two worlds they do
collide sometimes there is a an overlap
sometimes they are a little bit
mischievous and they cause us problems
and and they get involved with the
magicians and the evil ones from our
side but the the main thing that we've
got to remember okay is that they're a
creation they're not fallen angels
they're not angels who disobey allah
because the angels cannot disobey allah
the angels don't have free will but the
jinn do so there are good believers from
amongst them and there are disbelievers
from amongst them you know i've come
across jinn that said they were hindus
i've come across jinn that were jewish
i've come across jinn that were
fire worshipers i've come across jinn
that were from the illuminati or claimed
to be i've come across jinn that were
being that they are waiting for the
coming of the messiah meaning
and so i've come across jinn that were
muslim and they were righteous and so um
there's a vast spectrum just like our
side just like the human kind min al
muslim
from amongst us there are the muslims
and there are those who they are
oppressors and they wrong their own
south so
that's the world of the jinn in in a
very very brief thing but in the sunnah
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam we have a lot of detail about
the jinn we have a lot of detail about
their world for example the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam told us that
when we go to clean ourselves meaning in
those days don't clean yourselves with
uh with the dung okay because the dong
of our animals it forms the food of
their animals okay and likewise if we
eat and we say bismillah then the when
when we finish with our food and the
bones on that food
and we we get rid of them then it falls
into their hands and if it falls into
the hands from amongst the believers
from amongst the gin it will be full of
meat etc etc for them so this is another
dimension but it's part of the belief in
the unseen because we don't want to be
those people who if we can't see we
don't believe it etc you know it's it's
a world that's out there we can't see it
but it has very real implications
sometimes for our world
subhanallah and one of the brothers are
commenting you came across what you mean
by that so a lot of people don't know um
what your relation is so do you want to
go a little bit into that
yes so um it's not my it's not my
profession it's not something that i do
to make money or anything like that um
this uh is uh it's from rocklear so from
reciting on people who are possessed
from reciting on people who are uh under
the influence of magic or the evil eye
or whatever then the the jinn if the
person is possessed by a jinn meaning
the jin is entered into his body and is
now taking control of his faculties
then uh the jinn can speak through his
mouth okay and if you have a
conversation or you speak to them and
you judge by the way that they respond
then you can judge their religion and
other than that so um i don't conjure up
the jinn i don't play with the ouija
board or i don't go out and say you know
abacadabra and the jin appeared to me
none of that um rubbish but rather
um through the uh through the possessed
person who is ill and being afflicted we
can um we have these encounters with the
jinn
perfect
for anyone that made it this far if you
want to get a little bit more deeper
into this content uh brother abu
ibrahimostein has his own channel uh you
can just search him up but i highly
recommend you guys watch this course
called the rokia course with him and
sheikh mohammed tim humble if you guys
have time and it's too well worth to
watch but next question the or next
tenant that i want to talk about
magic and the magician
before you even go into the brother i
think i recognize you now
oh you have
yeah you have these videos on youtube
where you were talking about
um one of the
one of the people you did the rookia on
and it was like some girl who
[Music]
didn't know i think hindu or something
like that a certain language and then
like i don't know where she's she
started speaking the language like
perfectly and then the brother was
basically saying like oh no she's all
right she just she just needs some sleep
or she needs to go to the um
hospital or something like that because
that's what the gin
was telling
yeah
i think that was the yeah that was that
was the diary it's called the diaries of
an exorcist that's that's yeah right
where i sort of shared some of my
experiences
i remember hearing that for the first
time i was like oh bro
shivers going down my back
uh good to see everything's coming full
circle bro so
good to see that you do know him so
um magic and magicians right so
what are these what is the link between
it is it you know the western
connotation the more post-modern
connotation of magic is it anything to
do with that or what is actual uh magic
sorcery that type of stuff and then how
does it link to the person called the
magician
very good so um
magic is known as
arabic language so we can use it
interchangeably magical
um
is mentioned in the quran and it's
mentioned in the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam but
whenever we want to mention a term we've
got to define what magic is okay so
magic is a contract magic is a contract
between
the magician and one or more of the
devils one or more of the shayateen from
amongst
where the where the magician he will do
acts of worship and acts of submission
and acts of seeking nearness to the jinn
and as a as a repayment for him doing
that they will then go and
afflict the uh the target person with
whatever the aim and the goal and the
objective of the magic is okay so allah
mentions in uh in the quran in
102 and i'm not going to go into in too
much detail but the um magic was sent
down to these people as a trial two
angels came down and they it was a
knowledge it was a knowledge and allah
gave the angels this knowledge but it
was a trial
allah says that the angels said surely
we're just a trial from your lord so
don't disbelieve meaning don't
disbelieve by learning this
knowledge
so magic is knowledge it's a it's a
science which can be learnt but to have
any portion of magic okay allah says
they know and they knew that anybody who
had any portion of magic to learn it to
teach it to uh to get it done to
practice it to to get it done on another
person he has no put that person who
does that has no uh portion in the
hereafter allah says what an evil price
it is for which they have sold their own
souls if only they knew magic is
literally selling your soul to the devil
it's you selling your soul to the devil
and and doing acts of worship and
filthy acts basically totally degrading
yourself in submission to the devil
selling your soul to the devil in order
for some benefit
uh i want i want i want you to go and
cause divorce between husband and wife i
want you to
make that person
die or ruin his health and magic is real
and people have been practicing magic
since before the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam you know we
know that the magicians of pharaoh allah
mentions them in the quran and how they
had a showdown with musa we know that
the there is a type of magic which is
babylonian magic so there is
magic has been practiced through
civilizations throughout time and how
does a person become a um or how does a
person indulge in in magic it's not
something that normal people want to get
you know get involved in a magician
becomes a magician because he wants
money or he wants uh power or he wants
women or he wants recognition or he
wants all of that or he just wants to
cause mischief in the land and that you
know like i said so he there's books and
that kind of thing but they won't teach
you and you know it's not like me or you
now if we were to make a knot and we
were to start blowing into the knots and
start saying things nothing would happen
because we are we haven't submitted and
sold our soul to the devil but the
magician
the devils will be around him and
they'll work for him because he has sold
his uh soul to the devil and and if you
want we can go into um you know in the
in the modern day how does a person
become a magician and that's something
i'll leave to yourself
okay oh no bro you got any questions
nothing i think the first question
i do have questions but it's later on
it's different later on i want him to
get into what he was saying just now
bismillah then so we got uh three
questions inshallah if you want to just
answer them quickly and then you can
continue bismillah so the first one
islam have been telling me his time had
60 of people affected is this like do
you know anything about that
uh he didn't say that 60 were affected
rather he said if the veils were lifted
we would find that the majority of
people in our time meaning his time are
being afflicted by the jinn
uh and
you know so i don't know of any
narration which mentions a percentage or
a portion or fraction of the population
however essentially what he's saying is
that the vast majority of people in my
time are being afflicted by jinn okay um
and and
what we can sort of derive from that is
that this is not something new and it's
not something that we're just pulling
out uh you know from our own whims and
desires this is something that's well
known from the scholars of islam and
imam ahmad does narrations about him and
and jin and and you know he kind of sent
a uh slipper somebody was somebody was
possessed uh as a young girl that was
possessed and imam ahmed he sent his
servant with his slipper and and he said
go to the gin and that's afflicting this
woman and and basically say to this jinn
that hey uh you know this is the slipper
of imam ahmed and if you don't leave
this young girl then you're going to get
beat to you know a pulp with this
slipper and so the gin left and then
after the death of imam ahmed
it happened again and one of his
students tried the same thing and the
jinn turned around and said you fool you
know we used to fear imam ahmed because
he was fearful of allah as for you
people then we're not scared of you you
don't bring it basically and so what we
what we learn from this is that and and
and before imam ahmed we have um
that because of his taqwa of allah
because of his adherence to the sunnah
because he was a person who was so firm
upon the sunnah the prophet saws told
him oh umar you do not take one path
except that shaitaan takes a different
street altogether you know he's so
scared of you and so
this you know from the beginning one of
the things that i always try and get
across is brothers and sisters we should
not fear the jinn we should not fear and
be scared of the jinn if we have taqwa
of allah then they will fear us and so
you know just you do what you've got to
do and allah is enough to protect you
and and and will suffice you
um one thing i wanted to say to um to
this next question says have you noticed
how the evil eye jewelry has become such
a huge fashion statement now stuff for
like yeah so evil eye is a very real
thing so we don't want to delegitimize
the magnitude and severity i believe the
prophet saws said and you can tell me if
this is authentic hadith or not that had
there been anything to kind of transcend
allah's decree it would have been evil
eye not that there is anything but had
there been anything right so what are
your thoughts on these talismans and
these amulets that people use
so um yeah like you said the prophet
saws he said
that the evil eye is real
if anything was to go before the decree
of allah meaning actually preceded the
decree of allah then it would have been
the evil eye or as we say or in some
cultures they call it nazar and these
kind of things and in another narration
he said that nothing sends the camel
into the cooking pot and the man
into his grave after the decree of allah
more than i in
so it has real effects it cause it
causes people to become ill and die it
causes animals to you know meaning into
the cooking part means that they you
know when it when it's not useful
anymore you're just going to cook it and
you're going to eat it it's dead it's
finished so it has real effects um and
it had you know we have narrations from
the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam where um one of his
companions got the evil eye as for these
talismans and as you know it's called
the eye of fatima you you find it the
blue circles of different colors and and
then it's white um and or you hand you
have what's known as the hand of fatima
it's like a handout line again blue and
white colors um all of this all of this
is uh is not permissible
all of this actually comes under the
under the under the umbrella of shirk
with allah because your um allah is our
protector allah is our sustainer allah
is the one that safeguards us so when
you start hanging these types of symbols
and you start carrying these kind of
symbols believing that it's going to
protect you uh then then you're actually
committing [ __ ] with allah allah says
if allah should touch you with some harm
nobody nobody can um raise that harm
except for him and ibrahim
he
when i says ill it's allah that cures me
so we have to again uh come closer to
allah and trust in allah and seek help
and assistance from allah
before we go into that if you want to
kind of categorize the the different
types there's
evil eye and jin possession how they all
interlink okay so gin possession okay
firstly the gin have different um they
have different abilities to what we do
okay so one of the abilities of some of
the gin is to travel huge distances in a
very short space of time okay uh some of
the jinn are very powerful we know that
for example sulaiman alaihis salatu
the the prophet sulaiman they used to
build for him amazing structures and
amazing huge things and he had like a
palace made out of glass and all these
amazing things okay so the jin have
different abilities one of the abilities
of the jinn is to enter into the body of
the children of adam and to possess them
to basically hijack the body of the
children of adam okay so jin possession
is something which it does occur okay
and it occurs for various reasons one of
the reasons why jin possession occurs is
as a result of as a result of magic so
the magician he's gone and he's done his
worship and he's done what he's done and
then the gin will appear to him at that
stage when he's
let me give you an example of what a
magician does one of the things that a
magician does
he'll go out to a cave okay and he'll
light some candles in a cave which is
far away from you know civilization so
he's out alone
and then what he does is he lights some
candles and he sits in and he draws a
circle on the on the ground in the cave
and he sits in this cave and he like
meditates and he calls upon the the
devils
but he doesn't they're not going to
appear to him after five minutes no
once he's done this for days and days
and days meaning he and he's not allowed
to leave this circle so in this is a
small circle he defecates in this circle
he sleeps in his own defecation he eats
from his own defecation and he mixes all
of that stuff in and he rubs it all over
himself like i said he basically
humiliates himself
once he's in the filthiest of states and
the and the devils are now satisfied
that you know what this person has
totally removed his humanity the
position you know allah says
that we have indeed uh you know honored
the children of adam once he has totally
stripped himself of any honor and he's
humiliated himself for the devils then
they'll appear to him now and then
they'll say right what is it that you
want who is it that you want us to
afflict and then he'll have you know an
item of clothing or a picture or an item
of their dna hair whatever it might be
then they will go and they will afflict
this person they'll find this person
they'll start to afflict him
if and they'll you know they're not
going to go straight in if he's a person
who is a person of a good tawheed
meaning he worships allah he follows the
sunnah he does his protective uh his
the jinn won't be able to come
and afflict that person they might be
externally poking and prodding and
causing problems but if he's a person
who is watching pornography and he's got
a girlfriend and he's smoking drugs and
he's far away from islam doesn't pray
the sister that doesn't you know observe
the correct hijab then they will
actually enter into that person okay and
um
uh allah mentions
those people who consume riba in this
world
they're not gonna stand uh on yoma
except like the one who uh his the he's
been beaten into insanity by the touch
of the devil okay so the mass of the
shaitaan means here the possession that
he enters into the body okay so jin
possessed for uh because of
jin possessed because they fall in love
okay uh and this is something that
brothers and sisters need to be aware of
if you're walking around the house
amazed
i'm amazed with myself masha allah my
pecs are looking amazing my back blah
blah or you and you're not seeking uh
protection from allah then the jinn can
actually possess you or sisters likewise
with brothers going out of the house not
covered properly um
in the places of you know clubs and and
places of the shisha cafes and and these
places where the shayateen gather then
they can fall in love and they can
possess a person or they may possess due
to uh revenge so a a case which i i
always mention is a young brother was
running through the park at and it was
after fajr after uh after maghrib and he
was running through the park and he
became possessed and when i recited on
him the jinn began to speak and said
that it's he stepped and he crushed my
child he was running through under the
trees and we were under those trees and
he stepped on my child and he crushed my
my child and there's another part to
that story and that is that he was a
disobedient child he was disobedient to
his uh parents and his father in
particular and his father made dua oh
allah teach this boy a lesson and that
same time he he became possessed so we
ask allah for safety and security
pretty deep huh
yeah
yeah
man it's like all the
[Music]
i i definitely have more questions but
one question that i'm like particularly
want to know is like what what are the
uh symptoms if someone is possessed
good question what what are the symptoms
of gin possession so the symptoms of gin
possession they vary according to
the
type of possession okay so let's talk
about magic in particular so magic has
different purposes so sometimes people
do magic um uh to make a husband and a
wife split apart so one of the symptoms
of of this kind of
affliction uh and it's and it's regular
is that when the the couple are together
they absolutely hate one another and
they are arguing over the smallest of
things the tiniest of things and they
hate each other's guts but then when
they're apart they really miss each
other and the love is there so they just
can't seem to get together and make it
work there's just like a block on there
on their marriage um or they have uh
they have things where they see each
other but they when they look at each
other they see really sort of ugly faces
on each other's faces so they they they
hate each other and they get scared of
one another because the way that you
cause marriage you know ultimately
divorce between a husband and wife is
that you drive them apart they don't
want anything to be you know they don't
want anything to do with each other so
um that's that's one of the signs and
the symptoms if it's that kind of thing
um
if a person is possessed with a gin um
then they're gonna generally they're
going to have a hatred of
hygiene okay they're going to have a
hatred of hygiene so they that you know
we have cases where they don't shower
for two months three months on end
they don't want to be clean they don't
want to be pure because we know that
from islam is that we are clean and we
are pure we cleanse and purify our
bodies okay
other things a hatred of the adhan a
hatred of the adhan and that because we
know that when the other
oh
you know the amazing thing with this
with this topic is
is you see
oh no is he lagging for you too
chaton's working overtime bro
subhanallah
are you are you recording this
uh is this live bro because on mine it
says it is not live no no it's a live
stream bro
could you hear us bro
i can hear you i can hear you yeah
alhamdulillah you were you were kind of
lagging out i was like shaytan is
working overtime
i could carry on bro um so another
another sign of jin possession um is a
hatred of the recitation of the quran
for obvious reading sorry do you mind
going over the adam one more time
because you just cut off when you were
saying that oh okay so the adhan yes so
um a hatred of the adhan because we know
when the adhan is called shaitaan he uh
he flees and he he passes wind he hates
the adhan because this is this is like
the antithesis of of shaytan and
everything he stands for is the athan
the oneness of allah and the
messengership of the prophet
coming to salah coming to success coming
to you know the obedience of allah
shaitaan wants us to be obedient to him
so he hates it and so
when a person is possessed one of the
things that they hate is the adhan so
many times um we we hear of cases where
nobody knew that this person was
possessed but as soon as the adhan for
example it comes on tv or it's it plays
through the mobile telephone etc the
person he gets angry or she gets angry
and leaves and says turn it off i don't
want to listen to that so that's one of
the things a hatred of the quran
recitation of the quran the being in the
same room that the quran is recited they
just hate it they hate it they hate it
another thing
is um
is physical strength and
uh you know just i've seen i've seen
situations where you know one little
woman
it takes three or four men to hold her
down or three or four people to hold her
down and she's just a small girl and
that's because they generally become
very very strong when they are possessed
um other other things um gin possession
nightmares and frequent nightmares but
the field of dreams is one of those
things which i'm not an expert in
however at the same time you know if you
have one bad dream or you have one see
one vision that doesn't mean that you're
suddenly possessed so you know we need
to sort of say to people don't go
overboard and don't look for things
don't look for things um and and and of
course um an obvious one is uh the gin
speaking through a person's mouth and uh
or you can kind of see the gin on a
person's face and it and it i can't
explain it doesn't matter how much i try
i won't be able to explain it but you
can see a man's face on a woman's butt
on a on a woman's face and you can see a
woman's face on a man's face you know
sometimes depending on what's possessing
them so it's it's one of those things
that you have to experience and you have
to be in the room at that moment to be
able to to be able to actually
understand
i just wanted to add too there's a lot
of physical ailments too that i'm sure a
lot of brothers can find online if they
have proper sources but some of them
resulting around pregnancy too so
infertility inability to
absolutely basically get pregnant um
irregular periods that type of stuff but
there's a lot of stuff that they can
find online in child huge yeah a huge a
huge amount so just um in general when
it comes to this um i would say sort of
unexplainable medical problems
you know often they've done all the
tests all the specialists and yet
they're still bamboozled and baffled as
to what the issue is
it may be and again we sort of use the
word maybe rather than it definitely is
because um don't go and sort of just
self-diagnose until you've actually
recited on yourself that's the main
thing
so could you could you bro could you go
a little bit more deeper into evil eye
can you bring up the hadith um where the
prophet saws was mentioning that
i believe it was like an arrow right and
it basically doesn't hit the target that
has a lot of taqwa and is revolving
their life around allah something like
that i'm just you know metaphor
yeah so so um i i believe the narration
you're mentioning is actually
who mentions that the evil eye is like
an arrow
and it may it may strike its target or
actually if a person is protected
meaning by allah because he's a person
of allah and he's trying to follow or
she's a person who's trying to follow
the sunnah and they're doing those to us
then the arrow may actually bounce back
and afflict the person who actually
gave the evil eye in the first place so
the evil eye what is it the evil eye is
you have a person who has in his heart
or her heart like a deficiency envy
hatred and as a result of that okay when
they when they see a blessing that
somebody else has or they see somebody
else doing well it festers in their
heart like they're not happy truly that
a person is doing well or a person is
successful they're envious they're
jealous of that person and so it because
their heart is diseased the the arrow of
the evil eye it kind of it's it it
emanates from the diseased heart and so
it fires out from that diseased heart
and it can hit that person so from the
sunnah of the prophet
we have the hadith of
was a young man he was fit he was
healthy he was masha'allah he was like
he was in good physical shape athletic
and he had a good uh
physical
complexion and a good tone to his body
he was he was bathing by the by the
water and another man looked at him and
said wow and this is important he became
amazed wow he did you know like you buy
a new car and somebody comes and says
wow and then boof that car is just
breaking down or it just gets somebody
drives into it and writes it off or you
know you uh you you somebody comes and
says wow that's an amazing beard the
next thing you know your beard is
falling out and you're having problems
so this person said wow i've never seen
skin like that even on a virgin meaning
like even on a even on a a person who is
youthful i've never seen skin like that
at that moment as soon as he said that
imagine uh you know if you guys have as
a child we used to watch the cartoon
x-men and used to have that thing
cyclops where he used to fire this beam
from his eye and he used to be like that
red beam it's like that's what the evil
eye is he's like wow and boof suddenly
that beam comes out doof hits him and he
falls down and the narrator mentions
sahil wasn't even able to lift his head
after just a second ago he's fit he's
healthy he's taking a bath he's chilling
in his loving life now he can't even
lift his head it's literally paralyzed
him
they carry him to the prophet
and the and the messenger of allah he
says who do you accuse you only accuse
somebody when it's something bad who do
you accuse meaning who do you accuse of
having done this to you they mentioned
this person the prophet
told him to don't go take a wash they
gathered that water of
the and the russell that he had just
made and they gathered that water they
poured it over sahil and the narrator
mentions he got up and he walked away
like there was nothing wrong with him
so
it's
you know we we learn about the reality
of the evil eye and we also learn how to
treat it that if you know that there's a
person who has given it to you this
person was the one who said amazing blah
blah blah and then after that i mean
having problems you can go islamically
and you can go and
ask that person please take a wash
please take a hustle please gather that
water because the messenger of allah
said what is
to make a russell and wash then do it
give that person your will the water and
that person then he stands in a bath or
she stands in the bath and they pour it
over their heads and
they are absolutely going to be cured
straight away if they were the one that
gave you the the evil eye and actually
um it happened to me it happened to me i
was in the masjid once
and there was a group of brothers about
three or four brothers and they were all
there and and they were all they were
like wow what a beard amazing blah blah
blah i kid you not within three or four
days um my beard was falling out and it
was getting thin so i contacted those
brothers and i said listen this is
what's happened after you guys have been
saying this one of you has given me the
evil eye i don't know who it was all of
you all of you give me your with the
water so that you know practically they
you know when you have the plug in the
sink the plunger or whatever it is they
put that down they make the hustle and
or the wash sorry and then they just
take a bottle of water and they just dip
it in there and they just give me a like
a sample of their wool the water and i
didn't know who it was i stand in i
stood in the shower and i just poured it
all over my head at that moment
like i started seeing stars i started
feeling dizzy and and like i was just
like whoa what's going on here i've
never felt that ever before in my life
this was years ago by the way and
hamdulillah my beard regrew and and and
everything was fine so there it is it's
very very real and we need to be careful
because uh not everybody's happy when
they see us doing well not everybody's
happy when they see a blessing or they
they see that we're happy and we've got
a job or we've got a nice car or
whatever it is people are not happy some
people are envious so the message of
allah he said why would one of you kill
his brother when he sees something from
him that he likes then invoke allah's
blessing upon that so if you see
something that you know and and you know
that you're that kind of person first
thing you should do is you say allahumma
oh allah bless it you know
or if you've got a nice car you know
barakallahu
or whatever it might be and and that
will close the door to the evil eye
question
so
how would you
prevent yourself
from getting this another this evil eye
good question so that is from the um
from the number one it's from the sunnah
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
if you have um the app the fortress of a
muslim and i'm i really advise everybody
to download that app you can get it on
apple and android it's called the
fortress of the muslim and it has duas
from the life of the messenger of allah
what to you know literally every
situation you're going to find yourself
in there's a dua for it and it's
mentioned in this book you know what to
say before eating after eating before
sleep after waking up before putting
your clothes on when you buy some new
clothes uh what to you know after the
salah when you're feeling anxious and
worried and stressed when you're scared
to do is
one of them is
i seek refuge in the perfect words of
allah being shaytan
from every devil and from every animal
that stings
and from every evil eye from every evil
eye okay um so you make those duas you
make them in the morning and you make
them in the evening when you make them
in the morning you're protected until
the evening when you make them in the
evening you're protected until the
morning so it's like a 24-hour
protection uh that's one of the ways
sorry
yeah yeah
you know the the words of remembrance
okay and you can find that in
the fortress of a muslim another thing
practical step brothers and sisters if
you are living a happy life don't paste
your blessings online please don't paste
your blessings online because that's one
of the with the advent of social media
social media and everybody wants to
mashallah flex the problem is is that
people are getting ain left right and
center and they don't know how to deal
with it they don't if you you know the
messenger of allah he told us that every
possessor of a blessing
is envied
whatever blessing that you have keep it
to yourself because every possessor of a
blessing is envied and in another
narration he told us if you want to
achieve something if you have a goal you
want to achieve something keep it
private you want to start a business or
you've started a business there's no
need to tell the world keep your affairs
private a private life is a happy life
and insha'allah is a is a more protected
life
[Music]
that's a good point
really good points
very simple and comprehensive too i
believe that us even giving
you know
i mean just
unintentionally right i believe it could
be mitigated if we just keep the
remembrance of allah near we say
masha'allah
allah
barakallahu like these things they they
kind of it kind of takes the envy away
because how can you have envy in the
same time that you're you're blessing
something with the remembrance of allah
absolutely absolutely and
you know um
again he mentions this because he's like
the heart doctor and the soul doctor so
he goes into this a lot um and he says
that the in the person who gives ain and
the sahih the person who gives
who does magic they're similar they have
a similarity in that the magician he has
jinns around him
he has devils around him
and the person who gives the aim the
evil eye he has jin around him as well
okay the only difference is the magician
he does acts of worship and acts of
seeking nearness and that's why they um
that's why they congregate around him as
for the person who does ain it's because
of the the deficiency in his heart and
the darkness in his soul that the jinn
are attracted to him um as for like the
mechanics of how does evil eye work we
know very little wallahi we know very
very little about the mechanics of how
the evil eye works and anybody who comes
to you and tries to break it down in
detail in reality he has no evidence for
that
um
i remember when you were mentioning the
thing about the the four brothers or so
in the masjid that were complimenting
your beard um or the story of uh
you know the prophets of islam when he
would he basically instructed the
the man that was uh basically you know
feeling the other the other guy's
physique saying you know masha'allah but
not really saying mashallah and then
they took the water these cases are easy
they're isolated because you can
basically say like okay this is
attributed to this or at least you have
a hunch however when you're bringing the
thing about social media i found that
profound because
how how
how difficult is it to find the person
that gave you evil eye when you're
literally having thousands of likes tens
of thousands of likes hundreds of
comments people all just saying wow
amazing whatever not even keeping the
remembrance subhanallah
near and i think it's a very sticky
situation to fall into
personally my life like when i stopped
being as public you know it could be
simple things too like just storing what
you're eating or where you're at you'll
notice that life alone is like a private
life is a happy life just like the
brother said
yeah yeah 100 100 and and and the
problem is is
many people
they want to flex and they want to show
on whatever it is online but you don't
know who's looking at that you know and
and you may have people who are
genuinely happy but they don't invoke
the blessings of allah you may have
people who become amazed but then you
have genuine people who uh you know
woman shadrich
hassan the evil of the enviou when he
envies hasad is more serious
than than than and than than
hassan is like when that person he
genuinely wants you to just lose it he
doesn't care
if he doesn't get that blessing but he
as long as you don't have it and so many
people today
they they have hassan they are just
envious and so jealousy and envy are two
very different things and envy is more
serious and envy is more dangerous and
envy is subhan allah is is serious on
this point of of of of
you can give ain't to yourself and you
can give ain't to your children as well
so ain isn't necessarily due to hatred
you can you know often children have
ain't where we're like oh he's so cute
she's so cute and we don't say
allahummabadiq and all of those kind of
things okay and so
the brother him i shall say one of the
reasons why i don't use my face anymore
my point doesn't apply the brother is
much allah so beautiful that he doesn't
want ayn but the sister
yeah anyway so um we can give in to our
children and that's why it's so
important when you see something that
you like full stop
and even if it's a non-muslim
even if you see an if you see a
non-muslim driving a ferrari just
it's good practice to remove that from
your heart so allah mubarak because
you know tomorrow it's going to be your
muslim brother it's going to be your
muslim sister so we as muslims we have
to be happy for one another and try and
increase in our
us that we ask allah to bless what we
have
i mean you know i mean
wonderful question
uh touch on that point you just
mentioned brother is this social status
is important for business safety support
how can one basic
position themselves in that trustworthy
credible
authority type of you know positioning
that all businesses want to get to
without i guess getting that hustler
putting yourself out there
very good question
i i'm involved in business i have
multiple businesses
i don't have to put my personal face or
my personal
status online
okay so
you can you can advertise a business you
can advertise a position you can
advertise uh a social whatever it might
be without making it personal to
yourself
so um for example i i used to own a
social media agency and we were involved
in social media marketing so i'm very
aware of all of the the marketing tools
and and building influence and that kind
of thing and building trust in your
brand but
when it comes to your personal blessings
when it comes to your personal life keep
that private as for your business and so
you know
distinguish and and separate between a
business social media page and a private
life page and i think one of the
problems that some of our brothers they
or a mistake that they make is that they
join the two
and their and their personal life and
their personal blessings are mixed with
their business life and their business
blessings and so
there's very different to and this is
where we've got to be honest with
ourselves am i promoting my business or
am i promoting myself
and i might and and that's that that's
the difference and you got to be honest
with and it's about it's about knowing
yourself and being disciplined enough to
know your own soul
subhanallah subhanallah
another brother um and by the way this
is a video editor so allah mubarak to
him um he's writing i never knew these
things existed yeah so a lot of people
subhanallah want to touch on this
they're probably hearing these things
for the first time right so they might
be overwhelmed just like this brother's
saying things get really complicated so
how would you what cliff notes or
summary points should they take moving
on so they're not here with like so many
things to like keep in mind and they're
kind of neurotic
um number one
if you keep your duty to allah and you
follow the authentic sunnah you've got
nothing to worry about insha'allah okay
so you keep your duty to allah and you
you stay away from the haram and those
things and listen we're all going to
make sins
it doesn't matter it doesn't mean that
you commit one sin call us now you are
going to be possessed no don't live your
life and this is a really important
thing don't live your life fearing ain't
don't live your life fearing jinn
possession don't live your life fearing
magic but do what you've got to do to
take your precautions okay so pray your
five daily prayers that's so important
do your duas and your ad
in the morning and in the evening okay
don't go and plaster your blessings all
over the world if there's somebody who
has a bit of a reputation for being a
person who dabbles in magic and that
kind of thing
take take your precautions take your
precautions i mean i will be entirely
honest with you i don't eat at a
person's house unless i am absolutely
sure of that person's that and that
person he doesn't have this kind of
hatred or whatever and he's not a person
who delves into this because
frankly i can't risk it there's there's
too much at stake and and and i don't i
don't eat where i don't feel comfortable
okay um but i'm not saying you should do
that but i'm just giving you the steps
that i take
um so you know just move forward with
life brothers and sisters some people
they get so scared about jin they get so
scared about magic they get so scared
about you know the evil eye life just
becomes impossible and they just can't
do anything
you have to move forward be prac you
know be uh be positive and be practical
take your steps and then leave the rest
to allah like i used to have a nice or a
nice car and i used to park it i used to
go to the masjid to pray and the brother
comes to me young brother and he goes
look um
don't don't you aren't you scared of
evil eye are you scared of hyen i said
well look
you know do you want me to do you want
me to
not live in my means or or in line with
my means or do you want me to catch the
bus everywhere do you want me to park my
car like half an hour down the road
because i'm scared of ain this is not
practical like i'm i'm going to i'm
going to do what i do and then i'm gonna
put my trust in allah and if ayn affects
me that was with the permission of allah
i did everything that i could and if
allah wanted it to afflict me it still
afflicted me alhamdulillah you know like
just submit to allah and leave your
affairs to allah but don't fear it don't
fear it don't fear the jinn don't fear
magic don't fear the evil eye just do
what you do take your steps and leave
the rest
allah so i think on her leg though right
there but it was a wonderful point um
before we go on is there anything else
that you wanted to touch on regarding
this point um or should we proceed with
actual uh i guess magicians
yeah we could we can proceed i mean
like you've seen
you've seen the rookie of course there's
probably i don't know 10 hours or 14
hours of of of content there and we
break down every single thing in detail
so i think
to emphasize in one hour or 40 minutes
or 50 minutes you're not gonna get
everything so if this is a topic that
you want to learn more on then there's
lots of content out there i've got a
website we've got the rookia course
videos online there's so much out there
if you if you want to you know take a
deeper dive mashallah bro please text me
after this stream like any links that
you want me to put that people can
benefit from how they can find you
inshallah okay okay so to proceed with
let's say you have someone that's a
magician or you want to know if they're
a magician what are some signs of a
magician symptoms of a magician things
that can give you indicators without i
don't know moving like you're too
obsessed with the whereabouts of
everyone
good question so um one of the signs of
a magician and somebody who's working
with jinn
is he asks you know he asks for your
name your mother's name
okay so you go to him for a treatment or
you go to him uh
and and he he's he's claims to be a
spiritual healer whatever and you go to
him and he says right what's your name
and your mother's name i don't want to
go into detail but basically there's a
reason why he asks your mother's name
and you can
you can uh research that inshallah more
i've got more material on that but
that's that's a stupid issue why he asks
your name and your mother's name he's
then gonna go and start seeking the
assistance of the gin okay um he asks
for an item of your clothing or a
picture or an item of jewelry or hair
basically anything that has dna and
anything that can be used to identify
you okay because that's how his gin are
gonna identify you so when we um when we
watch the police programs you know and
the robbers have run away and they're
hiding in the forest the they bring the
sniffer dogs and the sniffer dogs the
the first thing they do for the sniffer
dogs is they make them smell the trail
and they make them smell an item of
their clothing or whatever so that the
sniffer dog knows who it's going to look
for who it's going to search for
just like that the gin they need a
picture they need your name your
mother's name they need an item of
clothing hair whatever it might be
something with the other with with the
with like the the trace of a person and
that's how they go and they afflict you
or the
magician you hear him calling upon iblis
or you hear him calling upon firaoun
you know many a time we've come across
this where they're calling upon the
devils and they're calling upon lots of
um crazy stuff
or the magician is somebody who he
claims to be able to do all things i can
bring back the love of your life you
know did your wife leave you no problem
i'll bring her back do you want to
control your husband a lot of women they
do magic on their own husbands because
they want to control them okay and and
do you want to control your husband i'll
make him like a puppy for you and you
can do whatever you like with him and
that kind of stuff and and so um again
there are so many signs of a magician so
many sides mumbling under his breath
he's right he's calling upon crazy stuff
uh he goes out into the caves and he
meditates and he comes back and claims
that he has jinn working for him that he
is from the only of allah and he's so
righteous and so pious if a person is
truly righteous and pious he's not going
to accept that he's righteous and pious
when a person claims to be righteous and
pious then that shows you that there is
no piety in this person so these are
just some of the some of the signs and
there's you know you can find books with
like 200 signs of the magician and
there's there's so much he says to you
you know bring me a an animal which
we're going to sacrifice go and find me
an albino rabbit or an albino rap for
example and
the albino rat and the albino rabbit and
the frog has absolutely nothing it
doesn't mean anything
he's just making
a fool out of you and he's making you
degrade yourself and make you believe
that these things truly have something
because magic cannot work and it will
not work for that magician until he is
you know causing others to degrade
themselves as well
subhanallah bro got you
the thing uh you know you brought
something in my mind the thing about
black cats black dogs is that just like
the culture you know like a mainstream
narrative or is that real that they're
more like a beacon
no absolutely so so things like black
cats black dogs and things like this
these are just omens that people have
invented you know um 666 friday the 13th
walking under a ladder opening an
umbrella inside you know all of these
mirror smashing whatever all of this
stuff has absolutely no basis in islam
and there's and again
you know
what what what relation does the black
cat have to magic you know there's it's
just that's oppression on the cats so we
don't even oppress the animals
subhanallah okay got you so uh my next
question is gonna be um how do you
protect oneself from affliction with the
rokia there's a hadith where
you know you know the hadith i'm talking
about there's 70 000 people that won't
enter jannah
really there
yeah so the hadith of the 70 000 people
that won't enter jannah that seek rookia
so how do you how do you interpret that
and and navigate because are we not
amongst those that if we seek rookia and
stuff like that
very good question so the prophet is
and i think we'll just mention the
hadith first so that people kind of get
the context he said that from this ummah
there will be 70 000 people who will
enter jannah
means there's no accountability and no
punishment for them it's like a priority
pass straight into jannah they're not
even questioned about their deeds
they're not even punished about for
their deeds nothing there's no hisab at
all they go straight to jannah and then
he went inside his house he left the
masjid and the companions were like who
are these people you know we want to how
do we get from amongst them because the
companions were the foremost in goodness
so they always wanted to be like number
one when it comes to these kind of
things so they were debating maybe it's
those who were born in islam they never
committed shirk maybe it's those who
you know were companions etc so the
messenger sallallahu alaihi wasallam
then he came back and then he said
yes
trust in allah this is the this is the
golden nuggets
why are they going to paradise without
any accountability is because their
complete trust and reliance is on allah
okay and so the scholars mentioned that
when you go to a brother or a sister and
you say to this person can you please
make rookie for me
can you please recite over me can you
assist me by reading over me they say
that this is not the perfect tawakkul
because inevitably some of your trust
has gone on to that person
so you then are excluded from the 70 000
because you didn't reach the highest
pinnacle of trust and reliance in allah
because ultimately some of it
went to that person that's going to
recite on you now a person might be
thinking well listen seventy thousand
there were more they're more than
seventy thousand companions you know
i've got no chance
in another narration the messenger
he said with each one of those seventy
thousand seventy thousand more so each
one person from that seventy thousand he
takes seventy thousand with him so i
think seventy thousand times seventy
thousand is something like 4.9 billion
or something okay so it's a big number
and then uh and then on top of that in
another narration uh the messenger allah
mentions and three handfuls of allah
okay so on top of those seventy thousand
and those seventy thousand seventy
thousand each one of those takes seventy
thousand and three handfuls of allah so
you can only imagine the number is huge
so inshaallah we do have the ability to
be from those people
but the point is is that
you
don't trust anybody like you don't put
your trust in that person
brother the point is
if you're gonna come to me and i'm gonna
read
i'm going to read something from the
quran that you can read yourself
i'm going to open the mushaf and i'm
going to read from a surah that is
within your muslif as well i don't have
any special ability i don't have any
special knowledge i'm not you know
this is not hogwarts and i'm not harry
potter i am a normal slave like you so
put your trust in allah and you do it
yourself
martial are very comprehensive i feel
like people lack that context and that
that that link between doing it yourself
and just being lazy right so it's very
good that you said that allah so we have
some questions so we can go on with
those before we continue
first one is can a child be disobedient
if someone did black magic on the mother
a disobedient rebellious child also what
about mental illness evan tamiya said
about the people in his time were 60 i
think that was from before but
so um i think the the the more relevant
question here is if a per if a mother is
afflicted can that affliction be passed
down in a hereditary fashion to her
child and the answer to that is yes
unfortunately um if a mother is
afflicted then we often find that her
children
um also have
an affliction and they bear that
affliction as well that's why it's so
important for our sisters if you have
problems you need to sort your problems
out if not for your own sake for the
sake of your children who will get
problems after you so if you have
problems i always say to people don't
sweep them under the carpet the best
thing the best way to deal with these
problems is head on confront them and be
brave put your trust in allah and i
promise you if you do that you will find
that this affliction was the best thing
that ever happened to you because it
ultimately brought you closer to allah
and made you a better person
okay next are you still doing rookia and
how have you been able to maintain this
as it is very energy and time consuming
no i'm not doing rookia anymore um
for two reasons
three reasons
um number one
due to the time thing okay so rakia is
not five minutes rakia is a
is a one hour two hours um sometimes
three four five hours how long's a piece
of string rocky is as long as you want
to recite for because we don't hold the
key it's it's allah when whenever allah
wills for this person to get better the
person will get better but generally a
good rakya session is between sort of 45
minutes and an hour as a minimum
when you're working and you've got
family commitments and you've got our
commitments and other commitments
it's just too much it's just too much
and
you know there's a saying
don't be like the candle which gives
light to others while it's burning
itself so you're burning you're burning
yourself down and you're yet you're
giving and eventually you're not going
to be able you're not going to be good
to anyone because you're finished so you
have to
prioritize and unfortunately um you know
that was something that i had to put on
the back burner however i spent a lot of
time making a lot of content so that for
the person who wants to do it and is is
struggling he can do it himself he
doesn't need me that's the first thing
the second thing the reason why i got
involved in rookia was because i wanted
to attach the hearts of the people to
their creator but you know once you
start
getting a social media influence and
your videos start going online i was
having people calling me saying brother
no no i only want to come to you and i'm
like no no but i'm not i'm not like
there's nothing special about me no no
no i trust you because i've seen your
videos and so what was happening was the
reverse of what i wanted to happen
people were then becoming attached to me
people were then putting their trust in
me and and then i found that i was
becoming a fitna a trial for the people
where people were like no no you know we
don't want to go to anyone else so we
don't need anyone so that was the second
thing and the third thing i got fed up i
got fed up of people not praying
being lazy
not living an islamic life and then you
want to come and waste my time you know
and you want me to read on you and and
you're not even praying five times a day
so actually my criteria my criteria for
reading on a person i used to ask you
know my phone rings and i used to say
are you praying five times a day and
they used to say brother i pray for i'm
struggling with fajr or brother you know
i've got work things and stuff i used to
say listen don't waste my time if you're
not praying five times a day you're not
gonna get better black and white full
stop so i used to say to them go away
and pray five times a day for a minimum
of two weeks
and then come back to me come back to me
after two weeks once you've been praying
five times a day and uh
allah the vast majority of those people
never used to come back to me they never
used to come back to me because
uh you know we like to be positive and i
hope that when they prayed their
problems went away but bottom line is
half of these people they couldn't be
bothered to pray five times a day and
they just want you know they want that
holy man they want the holy man effect
i'm going to go to a holy man he's going
to read on me and my problems are going
to go away and they didn't want to do it
themselves
so that's the difference between you
someone who is following the sunnah
following the islamic principles of
guiding people to kind of tell them to
work on themselves and fix their affairs
with allah versus when you see um see
i'm from toronto right and in toronto we
have all these you see all these like
hindu little places in like chinatown
and it also has like you know spells for
getting your visa spells for work spells
like these gurus that like you know they
have these basements and you pay them
like a little small fee bro if only they
knew that small fee is not worth the
afterlife and they'll do all these doing
the most bro just to give you this i
don't know i've heard of some reviews
that say it works something to say it
doesn't work the bottom line is even if
it works why are we surprised of course
it's going to work they're using gin or
whatever the point is taking shortcuts
is always going to backfire somewhere
either in this life or the akhirah and
inshallah we get the real-time feedback
in this life and we don't get the
punishment in the akkada but either way
it's not worth it
there's only one way to do things and
that's the proper way and if you don't
do things the proper way you're gonna
regret it sooner or later it's that
simple
100
next question we got is the evil eye
given by a jinn worse than the evil eye
given by humans
good question so there is some
discussion about evil eye from the gin
and
i'll be honest i don't know the answer
to that i don't know the answer to that
um
however i don't know of any sort of
authentic narration which mentions the
evil eye of the the jinn and the second
thing is
how can we live a life where we're
constantly fearing the evil eye from a
creation that we can't even see
you can't prepare for something that you
don't even know is there
and allah does not burden us with
anything more than we can handle so i am
unaware of whether the jinn can give the
evil i or that kind of thing but
if you ask me do you live your life
knowing that the jinn can give you the
evil eye or with the attitude absolutely
not absolutely not because i could be
sat here right now and thinking wow
subhanallah i might get the evil eye
from the jinn you know and and how how
am i supposed to function and how am i
supposed to practically be a husband a
father a son a friend a die how am i
supposed to live my life where i'm
thinking that you know any moment now
from the unseen i might get knocked out
you know like it's it's it's just not
practical it's just not practical
he's seen supernatural things that
people would find hard to believe can
you share some examples um obviously
that he would permit these uh for
example like people levitating
yeah so i'm not going to share any
examples
uh
muhammad tim has shared with me because
that you know that's
when we when we talk these things are
private and he hasn't given me um
permission but i can i can give you
things from myself i've been reciting on
people um and the the doors
oops there goes my phone uh maybe that
was from the gym um
so um
you know i've been reciting on people
and the the doors have been shaking or
um the the door frames are are
clattering um i've been reciting on
people i was reciting a person once and
there was like a balloon like a
celebrity like an aide celebration or
whatever kind of balloon
and that balloon i was just reciting and
from the corner of my eye can see this
balloon is just like lifting itself up
and sort of floating around the room and
then it pops and
and these kind of things but
there's nothing to be scared of in
reality you know um i i was in one place
once and there was a baby changing mat
and i was looking at the baby changing
that and it was it was flat and it was
then it the baby changing mat picked
itself up and rested itself against the
the banisters
and in these situations there's nothing
to be afraid of i just said listen is
that the most you can do like give it a
rest you're not going to scare me stop
wasting my time you know let's let's get
down to business and then and then it
stops
i heard of a one story from one of my
friends that they were praying and when
they were alone by themselves it was
like at like an overnight shift i think
there was security guard and there was
like a little couch a little sofa in
front of them and they were kind of
praying like facing
where you could see the sofa and
peripheral but no one really pays
attention to all the little things
around them unless you know something
happens right so just like clockwork
every night comes on salaat alaysha
comes he's praying as soon as he says
allah but he notices that in front of
him the couch that he had it kind of
looked like someone had been sitting
there before and as soon as he said
allah hooked up the couch lifted up as
in
something might have been sitting there
like a jinn and just took off when he
started praying
yeah yeah these things these things
occur but again we we shouldn't um we
shouldn't live our lives looking for
these kind of things we shouldn't live
our lives looking for these kind of
things just carry on and just do what
you've got to do i you know like i think
the
the message from me is we all have
enough going on in our lives just
trying to stay afloat and the fitna that
we have in our communities and our
societies we have enough to deal with
already that we don't need to be
worrying about the world of the jinn and
the world of i'm mean
and this and this like just just do your
best to be a a good slave of allah and a
good follower of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and and leave the rest
to allah
i mean all right guys we're just going
to take a handful or two of questions
anymore um before we wrap up the stream
and inshallah we'll have brother abu
ibrahimost name back on the podcast i
know brother angela's phone probably
died and he definitely gave her his
salams so he had some questions too so
inshallah next time if we get you on
that's fine
right next question on g z writes have
you found that people who have suffered
possession or magic allah uses that as a
means to bring them closer perhaps to
him once they seek healing of the quran
absolutely one thousand percent one
people who are suffering and then they
they take their they take their
treatment seriously they always say this
is the best thing that ever happened to
me they say this is this this this
calamity which has struck me is the best
thing that has ever taken place because
i was so far from allah before it
and now after it you know my life has
changed in other words they were on a
path to the fire of hell and by means of
this inshallah they've changed and they
they're going to get closer to jannah
in sha allah insha allah
next question
have you dealt with cases where the sehr
was done by family members
yes in fact one of in fact the most
common
magic is done by family members uh
family father's done magic on them on on
his daughter's mother has done magic on
the sun wife has done magic on the
husband um
and
you know i i'm i'm not a um i'm not a a
person who just wants to put down our
sisters for no reason but mainly it's
the women that engage in these kind of
things unfortunately due to hatred due
to this hazard that that some sometimes
they have and and it leads them to go to
these magicians and it leads and that's
why even when you look online at these
people who are
uh
are the magicians and when you go to
visit them the majority of their
customers are actually women
yeah and these guys this is not
misogynistic to say so this is just
we're playing state facts you know uh
we're stating uh uh plain facts about
you know the differences between men and
women the way we have emotionality the
way we have i mean which which wife
doesn't want to control her husband you
know but for some women it goes to a it
goes to a level where they they go and
get magic done but at the same time we
have men doing magic on on their wives
you know um i came across i had a case
where a man did the magic of love on on
a he was like 60 and the girl was like
20 and he just used her as a sex slave
for like 20 years or whatever it was you
know and and she didn't know why she was
with this guy but she was and there's
all sorts of craziness going on so it
happens from both sides it happens on
both sides yeah i've heard of women also
like stories that they use it because
they don't want their husband to marry
like a second or third wife
yeah yeah yeah hundred percent yeah 100
it doesn't happen you're basically going
against the laws of allah at that point
subhanallah well you're selling your
religion isn't it 100 next question we
have so the one who did it you should
perform wudu and give to the affected to
take also
so yeah if you if the person has given
you the evil eye and and there's an
indication that they have actually given
you the evil eye then they should make
the hustle uh or the
and then you they should gather that
water not all of it a part of it and
then you can just pour it over your head
and if that is indeed the person who's
done it you'll be cured straight away
inshaallah insha allah inshallah and
guys if you made it this far smash that
like button go follow brother abu
ibrahim hosney on the socials on youtube
on instagram just search his name you'll
find him inshallah we're gonna have to
get him back on the live stream too so
we can you know maybe even discuss how
to kind of do rookia i know he has some
videos on his channel but inshallah we
can have him back
next question if there's someone who has
99 of the signs of a magician but he has
a whole community fool thinking he's a
chef
what is the best way to expose him if
moving away isn't an option at the time
and there's a two part so it also says
since these magicians live among us in
secret how should we deal with them if
we call them out they'll retaliate with
magic if we can't pose behind them so
how do we act normal around them
there's no it's not permissible to make
an accusation that somebody is a
magician unless you have real proof and
evidence okay because magic
is disbelief and the one who practices
magic is disbelief so by calling
somebody a magician you're essentially
making tech fear you're essentially
declaring them to be a non-muslim okay
so
um
issues of takfir are not light issues
and and us normal people should not go
anywhere near them okay so the point is
um
you need to get solid evidence solid
evidence i mean one of the people i did
a course with he was from saudi arabia
and his job was to catch magicians that
was his job he was working for the
government and they used to um and and
that was his sole job his his whole
thing was
catching magicians and they used to
stake them out and they used to uh they
used to have cameras and hidden cameras
and they used to send people to them and
all of that and once they gathered all
the evidence and they'd go and arrest
that person so um
importantly though you know these are
this doesn't work off the whims of the
people
you know you you should go and seek
somebody else uh
his infamous his advice who is
knowledgeable from your community who's
upon the sunnah explain to this person
why you think this person is a magician
and then get the get the elders and the
and the people of authority in that
community to look into this person's
affair but as for me and you as just our
lone wolf we can't start saying you're a
magician you're a magician you're it's
gonna cause big fit now
yeah it's way too complex at that point
so jazakallah for your time it was a
wonderful stream guys if you have a
brother a sister a family member a loved
one a friend anyone that can benefit
from this stream please share this video
immediately with them like the video and
it's through your support through your
sharing that you know these messages get
spread and sent to the muslim community
because how many people including myself
didn't even know that i needed the
information on the stream and
alhamdulillah by the will of allah i've
gone in and i've acquired it but a lot
of people don't have access to this
stuff um so you could be the difference
between them getting this and maybe
seeking okay if they need help or
something like that versus them not
getting it um is there anything else
brother that i could do for you anything
else you have
no just in just an ending um i just want
to remind one another that
um you know
that actions are according to their
intentions and for every person he's
going to have that which he intended and
so
you know when you share these things and
even a reminder for myself more than
anyone else we have to have the correct
intention that we're doing this for the
sake of allah and we don't want any
worldly gain or any worldly benefit this
is only for allah so wrestle and fight
with your intention and and as the
saying goes you know that which comes
from the heart will go to the heart
inshallah so if you if you want to um
send this to people then have that
correct intention and make the other
allah guides them when we ask allah that
he accepts it
i mean all right guys with that being
said until next time salaam alaiki